good
morning millennials welcome back to the
morning toast and happy
friday friday gotta get down on friday
that's right it's friday and we're here
it's a friday because bryce is here in
studio with us he needed a special day
you know how like north needed to go to
positano bryce needed to come to work
with mommy he needed to see his auntie
he needed to get a lay of the land see
he's going to go check on some tech
things apparently we're having some
issues it's so good to have extra
support around extra tech support for
sure and he really just needed to feel
special i could sense that from him plus
it's a friday which is a dry day it's a
straw day we're feeling relaxed bryce is
here to kind of usher us into the
weekend yeah nothing says weekend like
the price yeah nothing says weekend like
acknowledging the space that you're in
this is very true so i would be remiss
devastated in heartbroken if i didn't
remind you all that this is the farthest
away from monday we're going to be all
weekend so enjoy it honor it yeah
acknowledge it
be grateful yeah that's all you can
really do that's all you can really do
after a week of rising and grinding yeah
this was a really great week toast and
otherwise obviously spritz peach lunch
yesterday oh we had our launch event to
much fanfare
the peach is so delicious you guys um we
were chugging it yesterday and there was
just like peaches everywhere peaches in
the drinks there was like peaches uh
peaches and cream for dessert but what
are those gummies peach gummy yes peach
garnishes in the cocktail it was just
extremely peachy yeah and i'm really
excited to enjoy
peach spritz this summer and the launch
event yesterday was so fun like the tick
tockers came through
it was really fun to get to meet we
finally met sierra from summer house
which i can't even believe we've never
met her i guess i just feel like we know
her that's how you feel when you watch
people on reality tv yes it was good to
catch up with the girlies old and new
and really feel relevant you know yeah
did you feel at one with your
tick-tockers like did that fulfill you i
felt really comfortable at the table
with fellow influencers you know fellow
talkers yeah you know i actually i was
like being the grandma learning how to
use the microwave like everyone you guys
were talking about i was like who yeah
you were i didn't know anyone yeah
there's so many new people that i don't
know who you're like gossiping about
like tick-tock drama and jackie was like
wait who makeup artist and i genuinely
didn't know i wasn't even just being
like oh yeah i don't know her yeah no
you you were being mariah carey you
actually didn't know her
literally and i never heard of them so
that just goes to show how it's a
different planet over there yeah but it
was really fun um i was like exhausted
afterwards i guess just like you know
drinking spritzes we'll do that to you
we'll do that to you it was really fun
and i'm excited for just like a weekend
full of bryce streis
spritz steeny vibes are you gonna come
over sure probably plans i mean i have
some plans but i'm not like booked back
to back i'll probably make time for
haraldson yeah come over sometime yeah
he's looking so good he's such a cutie
he's literally like
you know how much
of inner strength it takes not to like
go into your fridge get butter and
spread it over harold and eat him
it's the hardest thing imagine how i
feel no i know like it's it's actually
painful they don't talk about that like
the pain of motherhood like trying not
to eat your child
meanwhile you're trans eating you your
child's eating you and like i go over
there not a two-way street and i just
nibble you know but like i could be
going so much harder but i don't
obviously but like i could you could
i've had such a long morning already
i've already like nursed two times
pumped two times i'm just being like a
zombie cow and i heard a song because i
was on my new releases my release radar
a song that just like turned my mood
around you ever have one i've never
heard it before oh wow and i just want
to share it with everybody please
because it got me like i was doing my
bun and i was like yeah
i bet it's from tick tock no no it's um
lee bryce
rehab remixed his song it's called soul
by lee bryce blanco brown and rehab wow
and i just want that's my tip of the day
like listen to the song i sent it to
snitch and of course she was like yeah i
know of course why didn't you send it to
me if you knew why do you send it to me
so true i actually had a similar moment
like that but it was like a song that i
rediscovered what was it second wind
kelly clarkson's gorgeous i know that is
that a marin mara song that kelly
covered or is a kelly song that marin
maurice covered kelly's song that marin
mars covered it's so good marissa's is
almost as good like they're both really
good um but that also reminds me it's
not a story but we need to talk about
kalyoke we need to talk about kalyoke
because kelly announced that she's
dropping an ep of kelly oaky songs
kalioki is kelly's karaoke where she
covers other songs on her talk show
daytime talk show and it's so popular
sometimes it goes viral and i think the
impetus behind this whole album was like
people were unwell at her cover of
happier than ever by um billy eilish is
it happier than ever yeah yeah and it's
so good she does it like a it's so kelly
it's it's like breakaway it's like og
kelly no when she screams just leave me
alone like i felt that in my soul and
she got the curses out because she's
like you know our daytime queen yeah she
dropped those songs yesterday and
so good so fantastic i'm so curious what
the other six songs are i hope seven
rings is there because people were
equally impressed by that her that was a
really good cover too i love this
concept for kelly and she's really like
she's so good at covers and there are
artists who are like known for their
covers like miley and kelly's like
becoming that queen who also has like
her own discography of like original
bangers it's just sad when her covers
are better than the originals which do
you think
so many
can't think of it but a cover will never
be better than an original because it's
like it wouldn't exist without the
original
but so many times i'm like this is so
good and i didn't even like this song
what is kelly's what was the a moment
like this that's not her song right yeah
uh someone else she's singing about
american idol yeah like that was her
final song and then it became her like
her song who sings the original i don't
know oh man i just realized something
some kelly hater in their basement
totally she stole my song i just
realized something and i just want to
alert people magazine um i forgot to
wear my wedding ring today oh my god
trouble trouble in paradise i want to
alert people magazines i actually did
wear my wedding ring yesterday i know i
saw you for the first time in like two
years and i don't know i just was like
feeling because we were like getting all
glam and i was like what jewelry do i
have as like maybe i should wear my ring
maybe i should see if it fits right and
i got it on there even though it's tiny
the smallest ring i've ever seen in my
life tiny uh for a while it didn't fit
like when i was mucho pregnant and then
postpartum when i was swollen but now i
got it on my big fat finger so yeah um i
don't know if page six wants to reach
out to me for a comment my official
comment is no comment is there trouble
on mario based no but speaking of
stuff yeah yeah ben is on his way home
right now on a really long flight
sitting next to theresa judy j he texted
me early this morning and he was like oh
that's so funny i saw teresa from new
jersey's boyfriend in the bathroom at
the airport i'm like lol and then i
realized ben was flying into newark i'm
like they're definitely on your flight
and he's like oh maybe and he sits down
and then he texts me it's like they're
literally sitting next to me so it's
united polaris so the configuration is
like one two one and ben is in a
two-seater with teresa he should have
offered to give it
i know he put the part she put the
partition up like the second she sat
down oh she had no time for him but i am
getting little tidbits of information he
said teresa was facetiming before they
took off with no headphones on which is
just like not good plane etiquette and
now in the plane in the air she is using
talk to text so he can he like hear what
she's texting that's crazy let me see if
he sent me any more updates we actually
have a teresa story today and you know
what i'm glad he even recognized louis
because he watched the reunion with you
and he loved the real house husbands and
so that's the kind of work house
husbands are doing for
brand awareness
given that ben is sitting next to
theresa and he has the ben factor i
think ben will be invited to her wedding
i'm pretty sure teresa is a new investor
in spritz you didn't hear it from me but
one that i wouldn't be surprised the
plane lands ben is on real housewives of
new jersey we're we suddenly live in new
jersey
you buy their old house we'll follow up
on monday's show as to what things came
out of the ben factor yeah no but like
you'll be seeing teresa and louie with
the spritz sponsored bar at their
wedding 100
um so maybe that's a good segue into the
stories she'll be the new face of
pineapple spritz oh
that
that's something you are like literally
like a branding genius
thank you that's it mogul mogul energy
but that is it we didn't get to this
mogul space without ideas like that
hundred percent
um so i guess in honor of teresa we have
a hilarious story about her in ramona so
should we dive in and we also have a tv
recap we
fell behind this week a little bit but
today we're going to be covering real
housewives of beverly hills and the
kardashians the kardashians can i ask
you a question sure are you going to
watch real housewives of dubai yes and
last night a little bit started playing
at the end of my beverly hills but i was
so tired and i was like i need
all of my attention for this i don't
want to be falling asleep and i don't
want to be like waiting for it to be
over so that i can sleep so i'm going to
watch it this week and i'm so excited
yeah like me too i just feel like i'm
really full like my content plate is so
full i can barely keep up with the
things i have now my content plate is
full too but if dubai is amazing which i
think it's going to be then i'm happy to
include it like that's a delicious side
dish on my plate though yeah you
wouldn't skip over mac and cheese yeah
your plate was full i'm just getting
like housewives fatigue me too but if
it's not fantastic like i could it could
scale backpacks i have scaled back like
on housewives i'm done with oc i haven't
started atlanta this season even though
like i heard it's really good it's like
maybe i will i'm just trying to like
do less when it comes to housewives yeah
me too
i i'm just trying to just watch what
genuinely sparks joy for me exactly so
i'm just going to leave it to the shows
to do what they will and i'm just going
to be a consumer because again i can't
watch everything anymore like we used to
no i know it was psychotic yeah
psychotic um okay so without further ado
it is time for the fast five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
figs figs is on a mission to make
awesome scrubs suited for the awesome
humans working in healthcare forget boxy
itchy cotton scrubs figs are engineered
to be ridiculously soft and incredibly
durable they use innovative technical
comfort technology they blend comfort
style and durability into high
performance scrubs that help you perform
at your best whatever the day throws at
you so figs are functional the modern
day scrub but with a focus on design
function and comfort they have a
proprietary four-way stretch fabric for
a ridiculously soft feel they're
moisture wicking anti-wrinkle and
anti-odor thanks to the silvador
antimicrobial technology if you don't
know where to start with figs they're
super popular core scrubs never go out
of stock or style mix and match any core
scrubs with each for uh with each other
for a quick wardrobe refresh so
obviously if you work in healthcare like
scrubs are not that comfortable they're
not that stylish so if you want to take
like your day to day to another level
check out figs they're so comfortable
and obviously i'm not a nurse but i do
have two pairs because i value comfort
and i lay around in my house like
uncomfortable things and i [ __ ] love
my figs can i just say like they're
extremely comfortable like if you can
wear them in a bed like you're gonna
save lives as a nurse like it's just
it's simple science
figgs believes the awesome humans in
healthcare deserve scrubs that match so
head to wherefigs.com and use code toast
to get 15 off your first order that's
w-e-a-r-f-i-g-s
dot com code toast for 15 off your first
order
okay thank you claudia our first story
is platinum jubilee news overall there's
a bunch of things going on first
yesterday queen elizabeth pulled out of
the jubilee appearance after
experiencing discomfort at the tripping
of the color so with great reluctance
the queen announced that she would not
be attending the national service of
thanksgiving at st paul's cathedral on
friday which was today the cree the
queen cited some discomfort after the
trooping of the color celebration
obviously she's 96. the queen said this
[ __ ] is torture no the queen said like
my ass stood on that balcony in the hot
sun for literal hours waving to people i
don't know i'm 96 years old like i'm
taking tomorrow off yeah i gave you
everything i'm not sitting through a
three-hour service like please on a hard
church pew please respect my boundaries
yeah i feel like people are like oh no
is she okay she's fine like i'm 27 and
even i would need to have taken tomorrow
off after what yesterday was so like i
don't think there's a big story here i
just think first of all you have to walk
up a lot of stairs it's a long hard day
she had a long hard day yesterday like
give the queen a [ __ ] break no
and it's not like she's wearing all
birds right she's wearing a little
kitten heels she's carrying around her
purse she's wearing her hat a coat a
dress it's a lot it's a lot probably you
know spanx not skims because uh we have
another story about kim x queenie i just
think there was a lot of click bait
around here and i'm like fairly certain
the queen is fine no and this is
unbelievably relatable because like
these days are so long and she is
the center 96 years old even at 29 i'd
say this [ __ ] is torture 100 like
give the queen a day she'll be back on
her feet tomorrow yeah normalize giving
the queen some time off i do think like
a four day jubilee like might have been
like an over but we're just so excited i
know and they're so i mean we them
the family the people
i would say like let's keep celebrating
yeah the church event was nice because
we got like hardcore paparazzi pictures
of everyone everyone was there megan and
harry um they all looked great kate
looked great um megan and harry were
noticeably like not sitting in the
premium section like they were in like a
back row on the other side yeah the
second second row but not the first row
not the first round anything beyond the
first row is not the f it's the back row
100
uh
also
william and kate didn't bring prince
louis because of his antics yesterday
i'm assuming but it's also a lot for a
kid like but like he's a kid and that
was so cute he was behaving he was just
being a kid no i don't think he was
misbehaving and i don't think that they
think he was misbehaving but on a
balcony outside like you're free to
scream or whatever but in a closed
church like kids are notoriously antsy
in church 100 he was backing with the
queen saying we got away granny let's
turn on hbo max and watch the prince
yeah he's that was really really cute
and i think people enjoy that
like the royals are so unrelatable in so
many ways but like kids
will be kids kids will be kids and like
kids acting out like that is the great
equalizer like no matter how many
nannies you have how many palaces you
live in like kids are going to be kids
yeah so i don't think that they were
upset about that like it's so cute
honestly it's so cute and it's like
that's the
takeaway from yesterday great yeah
it's been really sweet and then also kim
kardashian is in london with pete
davidson we were questioning whether
they would go to the jubilee or not
there was an article written yesterday
that like kim has been begging pleading
to get into the platinum jubilee party
and she even said she would take a not
vip ticket right and the queen's the
palace said no kim also went to the bbc
allegedly asking for tickets from them
they turned her down and now page six is
reporting that kim didn't try to attend
the queen's platinum jubilee with pete
kim and p never attempted to keep up
with the royal family contrary to the
report claiming that they were denied
tickets a rep for kardashian tells page
six exclusively that kim quote didn't
even ask to go to queen elizabeth the
second historic event and actually
returned to la on wednesday the day
before the festivities began for a
pre-planned cover shoot
that uh page six is told that they were
in london to support a secret project
that pete is working on
so here's the thing
yes they left wednesday but maybe
because they couldn't get tickets you
know so i don't know if this is like him
covering her ass i don't know when i
read that she was like really trying to
go they she the article also said she's
like rarely in the uk so for her to be
there that week like shows that maybe
she was going in hopes that she could go
to the event like i found that to be so
relatable right and there was like a
quote that like kim and pete love the
royal family and they just want to be a
part of the day and i was like if i was
kim that's exactly what i would do yeah
so i don't know if
these conflicting reports like i don't
know what the truth is either way um
i don't think it makes like obviously
kim doesn't want to be like publicly
denied something so if she is denying it
like i understand her reasoning but like
it's cute like it's so cute but what is
kim's relationship with meghan markle if
any i don't think there is one maybe
because like literally the kardashians
are the royals of america but like so
are harry and megan you know i don't
think there is one because if there was
one we would know if yeah anything
yeah no and and megan's pretty public
about like who what hollywood star she's
friends with i know she's really good
friends with serena williams priyanka
chopra
i've never seen her and kim in the same
room and i feel like if they were
friends like megan would be in the skims
campaign
something you know there would be
something there would be anything yeah
even on the new show they're
name-dropping all the time
on the board of for yes julius jones i
didn't see megan and harry did you no
that's a really good call
so because if they were friends she
could text megan right for a ticket even
though i don't know if megan's in a
position to be like doling out free
tickets you know yes of guessing because
she right he might get right she's
already like unstable in her like where
does she stand in the family yeah so i
don't know what the truth is either way
like
i'm hoping that it's true that she
really wanted to go because i love that
because then like she's a queenie file
she's a queenie file which we love
and she said on the kardashians this
week like she's not chasing anything
anymore and really every door is open to
her there's nothing she can't do like
she can walk right into the met gala
right the white house the white house
etc she can't walk into buckingham
palace now she's going to make it her
mission yeah if okay so yeah that's true
i guess we'll find out what the truth is
and i think she wants a little bit of a
challenge it's been a few years since
she's had to work for something no since
something was denied her she works for
everything no that's not what i meant
you know like work to to get access like
the access is there
yeah so i don't know what the truth is
but you know what i'm enjoying the story
like she could literally go to outer
space if she wanted to she's trying to
yeah
yeah she could
that's crazy she likes a challenge yeah
so if she makes it her way ever into
buckingham palace then we'll know that
the story of her wanting tickets was
true yeah and i hope that it's true and
if it's not like whatever it was just
another fun thing that we got to talk
about and i guess and like if i write
like fan fiction about it if there is a
a cover like
we'll have to see it right didn't she
say she was there shooting a cover like
oh yeah there's always a cover i know
you know totally and or whatever pete is
working on in london maybe we'll bear
fruit i wonder what he's doing
i wonder what he's going to do now like
at post snl obviously he does stand up
he does like a little bit of acting but
like maybe chris jenner will take him on
as a client
she would be really good for him she'll
probably do more stand up he'll be based
in l.a probably more movies yeah
and maybe just like a stay-at-home
stepdad general just like doing a
celebrity like what celebrities do and i
think just like being supportive to kim
like kim needs support she's doing
everything
all at once i and she needs someone she
can lean on like maybe that's
his role i know and i get so excited
especially like in this most recent
episode of the kardashians there's a lot
of pete talk i get so excited about like
the potential there but then like i'm
constantly reminded of their age
difference it's like really big
yeah like does pete want to have more
kids i don't know you know
yeah it's like one of those situations
where it's like
eventually will the age right maybe it's
like right person wrong time like you
know
i wonder if kim would have more yeah i
think she would she said in that
interview
when they were all sitting with access
hollywood mm-hmm when they were
promoting that she would have production
that she wants like as many kids as her
mom had no for sure but like also you
are limited biologically like she's
like 42 yeah but science no for sure
doing things for sure but like these are
the things you have to think about when
you're in a relationship with someone
who's at a different like pace in their
life she had two kids via surrogate she
might have frozen eggs already oh that's
for sure she probably does she probably
does that's true that's true so kids are
on the table so i'm like excited about
them but i'm also just cautious of the
age difference
yeah no i think this is so real when she
was talking about him yesterday and the
fact that she is talking about him on
the show yesterday when i was watching
the episode and it's been like eight
months
this is a real deal no it's it's so
crazy beyond anyways wish they would
have been at the platinum jubilee
totally maybe next decade maybe next
decade are you ready for our next story
matthew morrison well you are ready
because you actually picked the stories
today i think it's important to let
everyone know yeah when just
i just want to say like i get a lot of
positive feedback when i choose the
story it's like i don't want the job i
think it's literally the worst job and
part as a part of the toast um and so
i'll do it every once in a while i'm
like today i happened to get here 45
minutes early like my my biological
clock was off so i did what i had to do
and i didn't mind it but i refused to uh
to take it on at full time well it
should come as no surprise since claudia
chose the stories matthew morrison reads
the alleged text that he sent to this so
you think you can say yes to the dress
contestant
he said i have nothing to hide so
matthew morrison claims the alleged text
he said to the contestant on the dance
show which led to his abrupt exit as a
judge was not inappropriate he made a
video saying it's really unfortunate
that i have to sit here and defend
myself and my family against blatantly
untrue statements made anonymously but i
have nothing to hide so in the interest
of transparency i will read you the one
message that i wrote to a dancer on the
show
he proceeded to read the alleged text
but did not show his phone or any screen
shots of the conversation right he said
hey it's matthew if you don't mind would
love to get your number and talk you
through some things the message read how
do you message someone without their
number dm
the message read according to matthew
morrison who claims he sent it because
he and the unnamed individual share a
mutual respect for the same
choreographer he said i've known the
choreographer for over 20 years and was
trying to help her get a job as a
choreographer on the show it's
devastating that we live in this world
where gossip rules and people's lives
are being thrown around as clickbait i
relax first of all he was like he was so
emphatic and like really defensive which
is just like makes you look guilty um
and so one i thought it was interesting
that he didn't show the phone okay two
um
i just have a hard time believing like
there was one message sent via dm
and fox did a whole investigation and
decided to fire him like that's just not
logical like the way he explains it like
there's a huge chunk missing
interesting do you think fox wants like
a big scandal around their show with an
inappropriate host no no that's true
and so like
first of all maybe he's just like a
creepy person but even the way he read
that first text message i'm like ew like
you are creepy like you are so even if
that was the extent of it like i can
understand someone who's in a position
like a vulnerable position being like
creeped out by him because he's just
like a creepy person um but i believe
that there's more there i don't think
fox does a whole investigation makes a
whole this is blowing up i don't think
that they would go through all of that
for one message
yeah
well i do hope that if there is more
that we do find out but also just
reading this message like with the
context of like this choreographer
whatever sure he it seems less nefarious
but remember the power dynamics of a
competition show imagine like simon
cowell and a celebrity and delay person
yeah and simon cowell dm's a contestant
camilla cabello
saying hey it's simon if you don't mind
would love to get your number and talk
through some things like creepy yeah
yeah creepy yeah and you're not there's
such like a separation you're not
supposed to yeah
like maybe afterwards they could have
connected but like it's it crosses a
line and i do believe that there was
more
okay but say there wasn't more and
that's it it's still creepy yeah given
the dynamics of this sort of show and
just given his vibe like i know that's
weird like everyone should be treated
equal but like i can't explain it like
if
i don't know if someone like
i don't know like kevin jonas sent a
message i'd be like he's so sweet you
know what i mean like is that wrong to
say like he gives off like a really kind
of weird vibe it's not wrong to say
but is it wrong in principle i don't
know i feel like it is like you can't be
i can't be a moral compass i don't know
all i'm just saying is my feelings like
i know i he and i think like a lot of
people find him like
weird and creepy and nefarious
they do find him extremely nefarious so
like maybe if it had come from someone
else and if this was the only message
sent that person would wouldn't have
felt like threatened
but that is the vibe that he gives off
like people find him really creepy
it's true we do
yeah cause he's always like making weird
faces and dancing with the kids on glee
yeah of course he's being brought to
disney plus you know he's taking off
netflix and i was like quaking for a
while but i believe it's on or was it
hulu no i think it was disney plus
i don't know i feel like hulu i can't
remember
glee was on fox
i know but like that [ __ ] never makes
sense no it doesn't but hulu has
uh i mean density plus has high school
musical the musical series which is
modern glee right that's true i just
don't see glee on disney plus i just
don't yeah okay
it's going somewhere so for the gleeks
just know like it's not over for us it's
never over but this is just like the
continuation of the glee curse like the
glee curse is [ __ ] real yeah it is
real yeah
so this is just one more
domino in the glee effect
are you ready for our next story yeah
ramona singer league teresa giudice and
luis
lewis i can never say his name no it's
not louis it's louie i said it wrong too
it's louis it is louis louie yeah i can
never when i was watching
the entire time you guys were calling
him i couldn't remember his name and
neither could ryan louie but it's
spelled l-u-i-s louie is l-o-u-i-e sorry
that's one way to spell it if you want
to be called louis you have to spell
your name that way otherwise your name
is louis and my book okay so it's louis
vuitton
who
louis vuitton louis vuitton is french or
whatever so they got their own [ __ ] over
there i'm talking about here
louis vuitton lewis
ramona leaked their wedding even louis
vuitton makes mistakes ramona leaked
their wedding date and location
she took a whole picture of the [ __ ]
invitation what did you think was going
to happen oh that's so funny what's
wrong it had the website yeah the
website password and on the website it
had the guest list the event the
schedule the location i'm sorry this is
as a someone who's planned a wedding
like this is unforgivable like i know
ramona's like ditzy and that's why we
love her but like come on all these
people then went on to the website made
fake rsvp's like hi lisa vanderpump is
coming like it was just a mess planning
a wedding is so hard and chaotic and
like i'm sorry this i know people make
mistakes but like this is not okay
yeah ramona's unwell
yeah i wonder what this will mean
logistically for obviously they have to
clean up the website and whatnot they're
not going to move the wedding or the
date yeah they're just probably going to
have to get additional security though
like actually i think people would
actually show up outside just to see
just to see um also the the rsvp guest
list was on the website so people saw
jennifer aiden was obviously invited um
jackie goldschneider was invited it's in
the article can you read who it said was
invited yeah but it's rsvp via website
you're not like it's not in the mail you
know
okay here are the uh
attendees or people who were not going
oh not going margaret
some hold on sorry mostly margaret
josephs and and jackie goldschneider
appear to have been invited right
jennifer aydis dolores and melissa also
made the cut okay you would obviously
she also invited luanne kyle richards
kenny moore cynthia bailly and ramona i
saw and i don't know if it's real it was
like a thing going around bravo like
instagram that room that theresa made
kenya one of her bridesmaids
and i just like i don't know if that's
true or like people were [ __ ] with
the website because ramona let so many
people in but like if that's true i just
want to say how weird i think that is
like they met on ultimate girls trip and
they definitely connected but like
what
yeah that is weird especially if knowing
that melissa is not right
so
if it's like lifelong friends dina manzo
obvious
um that's understandable but
that would not be i'm surprised that
ramona even got invited considering how
unpopular she was on ultimate girls trip
that's true but i think teresa like
wants it to be an affair of girlies you
know yeah this is what you do when like
you're a housewife you make it like a
bravo event and ramona lives just down
the street right over the bridge just
over the bridge
okay that'll be fun wait so when's the
wedding no totally and where is it no
it's not spreading no no but it is right
here on the website not the date but the
location i'm just curious where the
location new jersey
on the invitation oh i never heard about
it
it's black tie bryce do you want to go
to a wedding burn now literally ring
bearer bryce wants to go to a wedding
with him and magnolia
bruno boy we've like been ignoring him a
little bit he's been like exploring let
him live his life he doesn't he's jacob
tremblay he doesn't leave the room ready
to larp my friend
are you having so much fun with mommy
look at him on the mic he wants a bridge
of someone to say he always has
something to say do you want to tie it
for you he's lost his courage i know
what he wants to say magnolia if you're
watching i love you so much please come
over sometime i'll make us pina coladas
we could sit on the roof it'll be
amazing please magnolia i love you
please magnolia i'll sing my original
song for you wrestling's dressing resins
dressing resins dressing presents right
some reds and stripes and roses rice and
braggings rise and rises rising
he reacted strongly to that song okay
and by the way for all the people who
always
uh message snitch when we say anything
about her and put it with a negative
spin please let her know that bruno
would like to see magnolia at her
earliest convenience and while you're at
it please stop watching this show like
you are causing dissension between our
family
like any time we say anything about
snitch oh i didn't like her jacket yeah
margo call me what'd you say about my
jacket i'm like literally nothing all i
said was that i have no fashion tents
and i didn't like your jacket like
what is it what big whoop like watch the
toast yeah oh my god please stop [ __ ]
doing that snitches but if you are going
to snitch like tell her to bring nols
for rice because she's for lauren
totally tell her
bryce is for lauren just write that
thank you are you ready for our next
story mgk is introducing his mom who
abandoned him as a child to his
instagram that is this is so like crazy
machine gun kelly is introducing his
fans to his mother a year after the pair
reconnected for the first time since she
abandoned him as a child the singer
posted a photo throwing up two middle
fingers as he sat closely beside his mom
who perhaps ironically was holding up a
peace sign he said introducing my mom
they both looked happy to be together
flashing big smiles for the camera the
back story is that he was born in
houston texas to missionary parents and
was abandoned by his mother when he was
just nine years old he revealed in the
lyrics to his song burning memories
he it says yeah this one's for the mama
that i never knew i took acid just to
burn all of my memories of you i guess
now i really want to know the truth
how'd you leave your only child at nine
for another dude he also sang all the
years that you ignored me left me
sleepless in the bed i hope that he got
some kids because your only son is dead
then his father who raised him died in
july 2020 and he had said at the time
i've never felt a pain this deep in my
life
then in june 2021 he tweeted wilde's
story but after all these years the fans
are responsible for me and my mom
finally reconnecting i love you
i mean this is a nice story i just like
i mean obviously i don't know what
that's like but i can imagine like i
would be so like bitter if that were me
so it takes like a really magnanimous
mature person to do that and i find it
really admirable but like couldn't be me
i'd be so like you're kidding right like
now no and now like i'm famous it's easy
to wanna like claim me and i'm like
literally one of the biggest rock stars
in the world but like what if i was just
like an accountant would you give a [ __ ]
right and it's like i don't need you now
i needed you then yeah no so like i'm
like mad on behalf of mgk and i know
like he's not mad so i have no right to
be but like i feel like
i don't know like it's like extremely
[ __ ] up like yeah but he also like he
how old is he it's like 32. so he's had
like 25 years of madness yeah you're
just learning these facts right maybe it
gets old getting mad yeah and you have
to release the anger i don't know if you
know what kind of relationship he'll
have with his mom but maybe he's ready
to
forgive but not forget because yeah you
forget no and it's like
i guess there's something like deeply
even more
hurtful about being abandoned at nine i
think a lot of kids are like abandoned
at birth
um but like to have spent like almost 10
years with your kid and then like not be
interested like that's so hurtful
yeah um it also reminds me of piece by
piece by kelly clarkson everything does
no i literally watched that performance
of kelly clarkson on american idol nine
months pregnant historically crying with
keith urban um like once a month i know
and it's just like so sad because i know
it's all about how great her new man is
you know is not like
her father right the song lyrically is
like you know her dad abandoned her
wanted nothing and then like came back
to her for money obviously like years
later i mean now she has a man who's
going to treat their daughter like
exactly the way a man should piece by
piece he's healing her and piece by
piece like he's never asked her for
anything even though they're literally
in the divorce proceedings like what do
you want like a million dollars a month
and the ranch
yeah and now she's like just [ __ ]
leave me
[Music]
and she says i don't talk [ __ ] about you
on the internet well i guess you made
yourself look bad wanting my house
that's what she said that is what she
said she said and you know what i
actually didn't really put together how
probably like personal that song is for
her like she can really relate to it
yeah that's why she's going so hard
totally and now she's happier than ever
literally
but i'm happy for mgk like good for you
for being the bigger person could never
be me yeah we should do an episode where
we do all five stories and we have to
find a way to relate them back to kelly
clarkson it wouldn't be hard it would be
a breeze it literally wouldn't be hard
let's do the next story i'll find it
i'll find a way
okay a little human interest story for
your fifth story on friday to usher you
into the weekend and i'm gonna ask you
guys i'm gonna pose a question to you
okay what would you do
a woman discovered thirty six thousand
dollars hidden in a sofa she found on
craigslist and she gets a reward after
returning the cash
california woman she returned it she
returned and ended up getting more than
she because if she didn't she wouldn't
be telling people right get wound up
getting more than she bargained for for
in her craigslist haul after moving into
her new home vicky modu decided to do
some furniture shopping online according
to kabc tv then she came across a
listing that seemed too good to be true
a set of two sobas and a matching chair
that wouldn't cost her a dime after
calling the seller to make sure the free
listing wasn't just a gimmick she
learned that the furniture belonged to
one of their loved ones who had recently
died so i guess they just wanted to get
rid of the furniture and once the
furniture was inside her house she
noticed that there was something tucked
inside one of the sofa cushions
initially she thought it was a heating
pad
he must have had a price in his life
however there's actually a number of
envelopes filled with 36k in cash
this is literally like the book we just
read younger wife i was just thinking
that and without uh hesitation she
returned she contacted the family to uh
return the money and they gave her 2 200
in cash that's it
um okay if it were me
i definitely would return it like
i think you know some person might open
this up and like maybe they fell upon
hard times and like this was god's way
of like you know giving them a miracle
and i think in that case like legally
it's yours like keep it you know
but i think i would return it i would
feel weird especially if i knew that
this literally belonged to like their
dead grandma or something yeah it's
giving younger wife why were they
stalking all this money away no now they
have some like research into their
family history why why someone would be
like snuggling money into a couch yeah
i like to think you know that i would
keep the money but i would not i would
not for a second and because it's too
much money and also like it could be
someone else's miracle
right and also like i don't know i don't
think this is like a blanket statement
for like what happens when you find
money like i found 20 in a cab once i'm
like i definitely kept it well what else
are you gonna do you could have given it
to the driver but like he didn't sit in
the back seat i knew it wasn't his if i
found 20 in a cab i would have left it
for the next person to like
to
uh turn around their day you know what i
think i did actually i think i paid for
the cab with the 20.
keep the change yeah that works too yeah
yeah um
and so let's find a way to relate this
back to kelly clarkson i actually think
that this
couch story is kind of like an analogy a
metaphor about what kelly's going
through with her divorce like you know
she has all this money
and
she was giving it away
i can do it yeah okay kelly would have
returned money
kelly obviously she's like a
multi-multi-millionaire she doesn't need
36 grand she would have returned it and
maybe the sofa itself was from her line
at wayfair
i forgot she's really look just like us
mogul
mogu
just like us just like us i can't see
the difference um let's head into the tv
recap what do you want to do first
kardashians because that's in the order
i watched it um me too it was a really
good episode i feel like everyone's
story lines were like really strong
strong obviously kim's was the strongest
let's just dive in we got pete and we
got plane
um and i loved both equally i think the
way kim talks about
um
like the place that she's in in her life
i find like really inspiring like she
doesn't give a [ __ ] she's has so much
peace like she's really reached a level
in her career and her personal life
where like she's just happy and things
are working out and i just feel like
that's like after years and years of
hard work and just the way that she
spoke about like the piece that she has
like i was incredibly jealous yeah no
and but that she worked so hard she was
as she says so desperate for so many
years and i don't think the peace and
the happiness feels as good as it does
when you don't do that of course so
you're not you're not even able to
recognize it unless for years you were
working so hard right but if you're you
know
happy in your 20s and 30s and at peace
then in your 40s it feels no different
so i think just the sharp contrast yeah
for her is really enjoyable i loved
hearing about how her and pete met like
that she took the first step asking for
his number and when she said she called
the snl producer like she definitely
called lindsay shookus
oh
ben affleck because she was one on the
couch with kim like talking her through
the whole snl and i guess if it was
lauren she'd call laura she would have
said lauren why lauren is the one who
took her to dinner and asked her to do
it no i know but like she didn't call
lauren she called lindsay shook for sure
loves pete yeah i agree she definitely
didn't call lauren because she would
have said lauren but lauren does love
heat i'm sure lauren ships i'm sure
lauren has a bigger ship than us not
possible
um so i thought it was really
interesting how they met and then like
just hearing like their phone
interactions like how they speak with
one another like she called him babe
like i was not okay okay so that's
really vindicating for me since i am i
thought
i thought of you immediately thank you
it wasn't cringy when she did it so is
it cringy when i do it no i just think
the word babe like is cringe like in
books i read i'm like oh no i agree i'm
like who talks like that you
but
it's not cringe in practice like try it
try it around your house and also like
you said like it's kind of cool no you
could pull it off if you could pull it
off i i know myself like i'm not pulling
it off like i call it's like we have our
own language oh right you're a muffy
crunchalicious
diet coke big daddy move yeah
um say babe give me diet coke baby no i
like that no no no no no it's just like
not me you know okay get to know myself
so
obviously like the big question at the
end of the episode was like what the
[ __ ] did pete have delivered to the
plane right and why couldn't we know so
a lot of people thought it was weed
gummies like they're not gonna put that
on the show but like i don't think kim
does weed gummies like she doesn't even
drink
yeah okay that would be that would
explain why we couldn't know or maybe
it's like a spoiler for next week no i
think it's probably weed gummies that's
a really good point because i thought it
was gonna be like you know beignets or
donuts like something like that or like
a balloon or flowers and it did seem
like food because pete had these
delivered and it wasn't flowers they
would have showed us
definitely something of an illegal
substance yeah which is so not i mean
she's so crazy yeah no she's always like
cbd literally she probably took it up a
notch i mean doesn't pete smoke a lot of
weeds yeah like that's his thing he
definitely had blunts delivered to the
plane kim doesn't smoke once she's a
changed woman maybe that's why she's so
at beast
um even though chloe chloe didn't really
have a like a major storyline this week
i just wanted to say like i love her so
much like the way she was it's just like
every episode she's like who can i
support it's so admirable and it's so
selfless and like she was giving her mom
actually really good advice and then i
thought it was so cool how chris was
like this was chris's big moment she was
like wait chloe come in and say what you
said like get involved steal spotlight
for a second like
i just felt like that could never be me
obviously i just found that to be like
so incredibly like honorable and like
really admirable that chris had her come
in that chris had her come in and chloe
was like so happy to put everything that
week
on the back burner just like support her
mom who's clearly really nervous about
something that is a big deal and like
when she's drawing the bath and the
bubbles like i didn't even know that's
how you get more about me like she's
just a
queen it was so like
it was shocking because she's like you
know she's like a bad bad so funny
everything's about
but she really is like the most
supportive person in their family yeah
and she needs support i know especially
next week obviously her sisters support
her but like she needs a p
she needs a businessman beau like she
really i think that like
obviously her life is very fulfilling
but i think she gives so much to others
that i think at the end of the day she
gets in bed and she's like has nothing
left for herself i really feel that way
and that's when someone needs to come in
and give her that so if she had a stable
good man at home who wasn't running
around getting other women pregnant like
i do think that would do so much for her
mental health yeah what about a comedian
though it's clearly working anything
anything i'm not picky she doesn't want
to be with an accountant like mj told
her and she said no grandma like she
needs a guide that
mj met at dick's sporting goods like
that's who she needs
someone who can just be there full-time
to support her like full-time job is
loving chloe yeah
it makes me so sad and like knowing
what's coming now next week with the
girl who got pregnant it's like this
[ __ ] can't catch a break she's out here
doing everything for everyone and like
her life is also falling apart yeah
she needs bryce she needs she definitely
she needs a dog i think she has cabana
whatever yeah and then that's sad too
the dog's passing right she needs a man
she really needs to like stop dating
athletes it's not working out for her
she needs to
seek love elsewhere
match.com locks club yes something
um
and i kind of want to watch chris's
master class even though like when the
clips that we saw she was saying a whole
bunch of nothing like
in order to get to where you are you
need to be where you need to be like
what does that mean a little bit yes of
nothing some things she was saying but i
also think for you
you know what she like this isn't news
to you because you're doing what she's
saying i just like i want to hear like
from the horse's mouth no i know because
she said from start to finish she's
going to show you how to like build your
business and like be authentic and the
way she was talking about like audience
interaction like she was on point yeah
she was on point but i just have to like
tell you something you've built your
business
no i know i'm not looking for like
advice i'm looking just like because i
love chris oh like i was gonna look
watch for advice you know i think like
what she knows we know like we've been
that's what i'm saying that's why to you
it sounded like a word salad
because it's oh yes i guess it was a
word salad though
i love
i hate a world salad so much that like i
love it another iconic part of the
episode was the gwyneth paltrow of it
all yes now was that conversation like
so awkward for anyone but me oh i loved
it no
gwyneth is like literally this
maternal queen like she courtney's just
awkward and honestly courtney was also
giving me really awkward vibes when kim
was like opening up about pete in the
kitchen like i think courtney's just
like awkward relatable yeah because she
was making me like really uncomfortable
with gwyneth like and i do love the
sentiment like there can be space and
people are always pinning pooch against
goop but i think the misconception that
they had is like people aren't pinning
pooch against goo because there can't be
two women in
wellness people are pinning pooch
against goop because push literally
copied goop the name the branding the
concept like it's really similar yeah
and it's not because they're both women
no it has nothing to do with that there
can be multiple women in wellness but
like there is like a little bit of an
awkward thing like the whole celebrity
wellness website push goop like yeah two
o's two o's like nickname it's it's
similar so i just wanna say like there
is space for two women and wellness but
that's not what like the internet is
quaking about yeah and honestly i hadn't
really thought too much about it
recently like now that push is pushing
and it's been around for a while and it
seems like they they do really well like
i'm no longer like oh she's
copying gwyneth or anything no it's like
over but like when it launched it was
like oh and i also think that in the
years since they both launched like
wellness and all that like woo-woo stuff
has become a lot more mainstream than
when goob first started they were
selling like a crystal for 500 no and
like they were getting like so much
backlash everyone was making fun of them
but like really they persevered and
they're valued of over a billion dollars
really they have skin care they do
podcasts they have clothing g-label it's
incredibly popular with like a niche
group of people but it's it's and they
did the netflix show yeah the netflix
it's incredibly popular yeah no and
gwyneth is more popular than ever she
looks amazing she's clearly like you
know people even if they
laugh at goop or whatever you can't deny
that whatever she's doing business she
no and also with herself she's doing
something right she looked amazing i'm
like literally obsessed with she's like
top 10 one of my favorite celebrities no
and like she has what it takes to be on
a reality show because i just want to
hear her talk more no and i love that
she like did the show obviously like the
collab is good for everyone but it's
like really good for push because it
gives push like a label of legitimacy in
the well in this space because goop is
the top yeah top tier so it was very
cool of her to a like put out an olive
branch two agree to be on the show and
three like sit down with courtney it
just honestly i didn't think i could
love gwyneth anymore but like she was
giving everything she looked literally
rady and i was like i have to go on
goop.com like it's working it will never
not confuse me that goop and super goop
are not different i completely agree
boop should acquire super goop just a
free idea just to erase confusion yeah
no and because i love super goop i'm
wearing their no i'm not wearing their
sunscreen but usually i'm wearing my
thrive cosmetics which i love uh
i love super goop it's the real deal and
so is goop no i was extremely confused
goopy i was extremely confused free idea
so i just even though lovely costume 100
no literally i loved that scene um what
else i think
kylie and kendall were not in it scott
was like kind of in it
what phrase was chris trying to say
couldn't she wasn't right she was like
miss she was misunderstood and why
didn't they just google it should we
google it what
she wanted to say like hone your skills
and blank your chops hone your skills
and bust your chops no that's what they
were saying buster chops doesn't mean
she's looking for a phrase that goes
blank your chops that means to hone your
skills oh
i should have googled it when she was
saying it
it's it's not a phrase that's why no one
could think of it honing their chop oh
okay it's like not a thing because
nothing was coming to signaling yeah
yeah um so all in all it's a really good
episode obviously next week is the
tristan of it all and i'm curious to see
like how that goes down kim is the one
who finds out first and i believe she's
the one who tells chloe yeah but i
believe that she's gonna get the call in
the gym then the episode's gonna end so
we'll see it in two weeks that's very e
of them so i just want to say i'll be
disappointed because we're supposed to
be getting more substance yeah that i
will not be happy no that's what it's
going to be otherwise there would have
been more uh in the preview yeah when
chloe finds out that conversation
between mason and north in the back of
this car like i was literally gonna cry
that was so sweet so sweet and they
really should watch blended i knew you
were gonna say that because obviously
like the stereotypes of step parents in
movies is really negative and nefarious
and i think it's doing damage i agree
actually i think just blended
is
out here alone negating those
stereotypes and the kids need to watch
it it was actually a really blended
themed episode because gwyneth was also
talking about
the blending of families how she didn't
even live with her husband for the first
year of marriage because like it was
just so complicated with the blended
families yeah but now they're in a good
place it takes time so there was a
blended kind of aura around the whole
episode yeah no if like they should have
right when kim started dating someone
new she should have like had their kids
watch this movie and all the kardashian
kids but also kids in general because we
were like this too like when you love a
movie you watch it over and over and
over again like what a girl wants when
we were kids so they would be watching
blended over and over and over again and
then they'd start like one feeling to
blend to family you know what i
literally cackled at i don't remember
what like the
the context of what she said but kim was
in her interview and she was like oh i'm
just a [ __ ]
i literally like i was just not
expecting her to say that and i don't
even remember what she was talking about
i like audibly like cackled i was like
yeah when she was saying how like at
first she was just dtf with pete and she
wouldn't want to share if their
relationship wasn't going anywhere and
she'd look dumb or just like a [ __ ]
yeah i cackled that was so [ __ ] funny
yeah and that was obviously like clearly
her thought process
yeah
but i need to meet pete because
like i have hope now that he might be on
the show like next season or something
no but i want to meet him in real life
because the way that people talk about
him and he's she's not the only one like
recently jack harlow like interviewed
him and talked about how and he he said
the same things about people like he's
so genuine he makes you feel you know
what it is
it's the benefit
peter has the benefit pete so kim's
coming for your man 100
because she was like yeah he's funny and
that's what everyone knows but like
that's literally like i don't even care
like that's not it yeah but just so
there's something about him like he's
jesus i'm wanna meet him and i want to
know what she's talking about he has
that
ben factor
potential cult leader if you use your
if you use your powers for good or evil
like you either become pete or you
become keith from nexam yeah
yeah yeah interesting um so the real
hospice beverly hills also was on last
night and honestly like i feel so
confused
i don't know what's going on i feel
really confused for a lot of reasons one
like i i do feel as though garcelle has
found herself in a place where she's
kind of like the voice of reason this
season
when erica was like you know a lot of
the victims could be lying about not
getting paid i can't like beyond
but i'm confused by garcelle because
crystal and sutton are close correct
sutton and garcelle are extremely close
sutton and crystal are good
i would say friends it seems like she's
trying to drive a wedge between crystal
and sutton yes because first of all and
she's just like she's calling kyle out
for being a potster which she is but
like garcelle is the biggest boxer last
week no one even mentioned how like she
was the one who made that whole couch
scene into a fight because uh sutton and
dorit had already buried the hatchet and
then this week she brought crystal over
and then she threw crystal under the bus
like you were setting up sutton in that
bar scene in tahoe so she's kind of like
she's the voice of reason but she's also
like a big time potstar but like no
one's saying anything yeah i do think
for garcelle the way she's coming at it
it's like sutton is her real friend in
real life and she's coming to all of
these situations trying to defend her
friend and it must have bothered her
this thing from last season also last
week she wanted all the girls to know
that her friend sutton is is is fine
with dorit now like she keeps trying to
help something sometimes you know it has
the opposite effect but sometimes
it doesn't and i do think i mean any
goodwill that like crystal earned last
season because i liked her by the end of
last season she's it's a second season
curse she's having a she didn't but she
didn't have an amazing first season but
she had a fun decently likable first
season after these
two episodes okay so let's see like kind
of the worst no okay so last week i was
like i couldn't follow what she was
saying i thought she was being really
sensitive and like distressed impressed
and then this episode
i feel like
she's doing
literally the same thing she did last
season
and she doesn't want anyone to like come
at her for the words she's using but
okay let's just let's be real with one
another when she said
what sutton said she said something
really bad before like the footage that
we saw and that she um it was really
dark and disturbing and problematic what
it came to mind for you
oh nothing specific but if i had to
conjure something up like
i don't know she used the a slur i
thought she said like maybe like the n
word right so she's putting this out
there
and so that's obviously i think where a
lot of people's brains went
and not only she not clearing it up
she's doubling down on the words she
used and she doesn't want anyone to come
at her for the words that she's using
but she's not going to share what sutton
said but here's the thing i mean the
fact that she won't share what she said
makes me feel like
it's it's really bad or it's not that
bad it's a nothing burger right and she
can keep using these big words to
justify like why because
it is yeah right and uh also if sutton
had said something really that bad or
used to slur they would have aired it
yeah and also in this moment they would
be showing it yeah maybe they don't know
what she's talking about right and kyle
was there and then chris crystal keeps
dismissing kyle because she was drunk
and so like it is possible like she was
drunk remember she's in the splits and
the margaritas it is possible that she
doesn't remember but crystal's just
being like really weird like gatekeeping
this whole situation yeah no she i i'm
completely not with her if she would
just share what it was we could deal
with it and sudden knows what she's
talking about though because they said
they had a conversation and sudden
apologized no that's about the
what we did yeah oh sutton is now
worried that she said something that she
forgot right right and that's why she
just doesn't want to deal with it but i
think actually they're making it into a
bigger thing by being like i'm not
saying no like crystal is just throwing
sutton under the bus because if
something if crystal had what you know
whatever it is to back up what she's
saying like she would share it yeah
i also felt like garcelle's question to
crystal about that scenario was kind of
random and like out of nowhere like i
don't feel like she was trying to set up
sutton in that moment i think they were
having like a heated drunk awkward
conversation about race yeah but it's
obviously something that was on
garcelle's mind for right right in the
interest of talking about things that
are people
right here here we go yeah so garcelle
is like really turning into like someone
i
i'm like
rooting for like the most even though a
lot of her actions do confuse me like i
don't know really what her goal is ever
you know yeah i think her goal is to
protect syndicate her friend
and be interesting on the show and also
like keep it real like call out like a
lot of the hypocrisy in this group yeah
lisa arena was not on this episode
no but there's now drama between rena
and kathy hilton i literally cannot keep
up i have no idea what's going on like
this guy patrick
i don't know and something like text
messages i wasn't keeping up until today
and all i saw today was that like she
discovered that kathy hilton hired
someone to leak something about her yeah
i can't follow it but we'll get there
we'll yeah um
so yeah eric didn't go to sun's party
i'm like so over erica like the way
she's just so
rude and i like how she
apologized to the entire group she's
like i know last year like i was wild
like you know and they cut to all the
clips and every clip she's yelling at
sutton and so she doesn't feel like she
owes that apology to sutton but she even
feels like sudden knows her an apology
like it's so moronic right and when she
was sitting at the table being like
sutton didn't apologize to me she
apologized to everyone it's like wait
you're mad that sutton didn't apologize
to you would you even accept and
apologize for something like you guys
are so far gone you're beyond apologies
yeah beyond apologies she's really
pissing me off that's why you're not
going her opening because she didn't
apologize like yeah you can't even
justify yeah um
i like sutton's dress from the designer
oh okay let's talk about the designer
like i mean the whole thing is so silly
but i did like the dress it was fine the
whole thing is so dumb yeah and i have a
really dumb question like what is
couture
as opposed to just like
couture is like runway stuff as opposed
to like stuff that just gets in the
store which is ready to wear
are you sure no
i i want to google this maybe it's like
the way it's made maybe it's like
atelier yeah something what is
because like sutton doesn't even wear
from
some things around that are on the
runway or in the store i think a tour is
like stuff that's not sold in stores
what is couture
the design and manufacturer fashion will
close to a client's specific
requirements and measurements so it's
custom
why not say custom literally
it's uh
okay
still i'm confused yeah whatever she
only works couture no and like it's not
even that cute and like i liked the
dress and i liked the beat no and it's
like okay you have this couture store
and you sell kyle like shahida like make
it make sense
good point i also want more diana
jenkins which is it's obviously nice of
something to carry like kyle's crap but
it's like it's off-brand it's it's not
uchika-chan so her store says sutton
established 1979 at first i thought that
was one year she was born and i was like
oh that's really cute she was
established in 1979 but that's not the
year she was born yeah she has a that
would make her like no that would make
her like what 43
no yeah yeah
and make her four that was really good
math i'd make her 43. are you sure does
google is she strike birthday i don't
think she's 43 is what i'm saying she's
older or younger older sutton's track
age
50 years she was born in 1971. maybe the
one wasn't another nine was away it was
like one with that little curly thing at
the top okay interesting then that's
really cute because i was like has she
had a store for 40 years no way
and we keep having openings
no way
so it was cute it was fun um
they're going to punta mita like a trip
is like we need the trip like for
something to happen like yeah yeah like
they're all like distressed even though
they just came from palm springs they
were there for one night yeah when they
were sitting there in the morning like
oh what are they doing today
leaving i was shook where's diana
where's diana
what do we want diana when do we want it
now she charted the plane for next week
like thank you thank you queen thank you
queen and i just want to die on a
reality show 100
and i guess that's it it would be what
would we be called tonight we think
doing diana
yeah do it with diana princess diana
love
um okay that's our show it's friday you
guys i hope you get prince streisand
he's being so good he was so good you
guys look it's try some stripes because
i have the pillow right here he's
probably shook it's like looking in a
mirror i love you my angel you love your
mommy thank you happy team to work with
mommy today thank you guys so much for
listening to the morning shows the
millennium morning show where we deliver
the fast five stories that you need to
know everybody right on youtube so if
you're watching this on youtube
subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up what do
you want people to do subscribe
how how could they do that
make yourself a gmail account and
subscribe like click subscribe what else
oh okay and give this video a thumbs up
we're also available as podcasting
podcasts can be found outside spotify
institute public reviews all the places
where we listen to podcasts by not
someone just leave a five star view
about how beautiful stunning and smart
we are have an amazing weekend and we'll
see you on monday an amazing weekend
make it amazing you guys amazing it's
the weekend first weekend of summer
enjoy goodbye goodbye bibbidi bye stress
i love you
you